here this is my first zoom
so oh it is okay gotta get on your level
you know
yeah all right let me add this to the
story cool
yeah go for it yeah i'm ready when you
are man oh sorry i'm late
no no worries just wanna introduce you
to um
my fan base this is dr brian keating
distinguished professor of physics at
ucsd
he's the inventor of the bicep telescope
which we'll be talking about
and the fearless host of my favorite
podcast
into the impossible i just want to start
off by saying congratulations
on 100 episodes thank you
trying to get through them all you know
through this quarantine
i've learned a lot pandemic podcast
that's what i call it the pandemic
podcast
yes and i've also been reading your book
losing the nobel prize which i'm on my
third
uh pass of it and let me uh
it's more than i read it well this time
um what i'm doing is i'm actually
i'm actually highlighting everything
with a format
um because one of the questions that i
had for you
was when when i first read it um i
pictured it in my mind as a movie
right away and i was like oh
there's a an amazing story here um
maybe we can talk about it a little more
as we go on yeah
absolutely i like how
you've documented not only history but
your legacy
and been able to articulate to the lay
person
a perfect image of
how things work as a physicist
astrophysicist
or cosmetologist i mean cosmologist you
know
and that's my joke yeah i'm stealing my
best lines
you know so um yeah i'm just i love the
book
um and thank you for contributing that
to society and history
so thank you yeah
you definitely are uh one of the
intended audience
uh targets that i wrote the book for
young people that
aspire to do great things and sometimes
we come up short
sometimes we're perfectly imperfect but
we all got to keep
keep the struggle alive well you have so
you have five children
and uh that you said that um how
so i have siblings i'm the oldest of
seven and my youngest sibling
uh 14 15 years old so how do you
how are you getting your children
interested in this field or how do you
motivate young people to pursue that
passion
in physics specifically
yeah well you know some of them are are
too young to appreciate physics so
they're just doing uh
quantitative biology at this point you
know when they're two years old it's a
little hard to do physically
i'm just kidding the very young ones are
not doing anything but this is
that's right yeah he's doing uh you know
quantum physics for his uh
for his junior high school science fair
uh he's uh he's
he's an exception but yeah my kids are
the one thing i want to stoke in my kids
is curiosity so today i was driving up
to school
one of them kept me up late with my wife
and you know today i'm just kind of
bleary-eyed
and then my my eight-year-old he's just
like daddy is it possible for like
a sonic black hole to suck in sound
uh another one's asking me you know the
uh what's it like
um if this if the ocean had no
salt in it if it was fresh water would
the waves be
as big as they are and i'm like i don't
know actually that's a very good
question that's a scientific question
and so the one thing i don't want to say
is um
yes next question you know basically i
want to encourage them
to keep asking questions the i always
say to my graduate students i've got you
know i've had
14 graduate students in the last 16
years
i'm pretty blessed to say that very few
people have that many graduate students
as me and these are young people younger
than you even that put their trust in
in my leadership and my stewardship and
i always say to them you know my job is
to get you to your next job
but then it's your job after that and
that can only be accomplished especially
in this economy by maintaining a curious
relentless passion for learning
and and you know we'll talk maybe a
little bit later about the difference
between
knowledge and wisdom because i try to
cultivate that in my kids as well
okay do you think that curiosity is um
somehow sparked with like
creativity too how does how do they go
hand in hand or
yeah well people don't usually think of
physics as like a creative sport you
know like behind me i've got this
amazing painting if you can see that
back there uh by uh
by the get the host today um so i look
to art
for inspiration i look to uh nature
for kind of um not guidance on how to
be wise but to be curious so nature
is written in the language of
mathematics that's what my friend
galileo galilei used to say that the
language
the book of nature is written in the
language of mathematics so to understand
uh you have to know some mathematics or
at least appreciate mathematics that's
the baseline
you can be curious about mathematics you
can do a lot without being stephen
wolfram or eric weinstein
but but the bottom line is you have to
have a baseline
familiarity with mathematics what i find
unfortunate
is that physicists in particular
disparage philosophy
philosophy i don't know if you know this
but philosophy means love of knowledge
so it's um so it's amazing because why
would you not want to love
knowledge so i have people that uh say
things not on my show because i don't
have them
like lawrence krauss very very you know
he he basically thinks that uh
philosophy is totally worthless and and
i think uh in those
types of of instances you know you get
what you pay for if you
if you're not willing to consider the
deepest questions as having a value
in and of themselves if only things are
worthy of investigating if they can be
looked at mathematically
i think we've got a big problem so my
main thing is to be curious i think the
first people that were curious were
philosophers
i don't think that you know lawrence
krauss or even me or somebody is wiser
than aristotle and aristotle didn't have
access to a
large hadron collider so i i don't think
it's fair to
to denigrate philosophy in fact i think
it's the underpinning of all of math
which is the underpinning of physics so
curiosity plus philosophy can probably
get you past the
hurdle of mathematics but uh but i'll
say for sure
you can't succeed as a scientist without
curiosity
and oftentimes it does is you hinted at
lead to creativity
as well mathematically physically and
otherwise where did that line and
philosophy get blurred because then you
got
aristotle has you know contributed to
music for example
you know with the sound waves and you
know galileo
his his father was a musician as well
but so it's like when did philosophers
separate and then physicists evolved
yeah that's a good question i've got a
book on my couch over here
i can't see it but i'll bring it over
it's by frank wilcheck who won the
2004 nobel prize in physics
i almost picked up this book by accident
which is which is full of wisdom
also i'm writing my second book is going
to be kind of a knock off of
tim ferriss's tools of titans calling it
lessons of laureates
or lessons from laureates or think like
a nobel prize winner we'll talk about
that later but getting back to
um to the ancient greeks so you got an
exclusive there and miguel
um so frank wilcheck who won the nobel
prize i said
he talks about uh philosophy for about
half of this book which is
which is a wonderful book he was on my
podcast into the impossible podcast just
last week
and he looks looks at all the ways that
art
music even are influencing and influence
physicists so
here's newton's experiments with prisms
over here
color and then manifest of color in in
great art
and how you could even look at
principles and physics that he studied
um which is called a complementarity and
uh and look at you know when you pick as
you know you take the different colors
and you add or subtract them that has a
physical effect
so here uh where this wheel is over here
is like a color wheel that you can spin
and people did experiments on colors for
many many years
and then he'll look at um he'll look at
famous paintings let's see i'm trying to
find the one
that we he and i talked about but uh
you'll look at paintings where
um you can transpose the different
colors and you'll get a totally
different image and i think that's
really fascinating to me and how you can
experiment with complementarity
and even from like an eastern tradition
you know the yin yang symbol etc
so he looks at that and he asks the
question of
how far back does beauty go and beauty
goes all the way back to
the ancient greeks so he talks about
pythagoras
and the and the harmonies of different
strings and
uh and pythagorean ratios and chords and
stuff you know much better than me i
always joke
that you know the only instrument i play
you know is the iphone
uh that's all i can play i don't have a
billionth of your of your talent
but um you know from from
the ancient greeks to today there's
always been this deep link between
music and art and and science in fact my
my best friend uh professor stefan
alexander wrote
a book i'm gonna go grab in the back the
jazz of physics
how many books i've got miguel i've read
41 books
since the pandemic kicked in and i've
had 41 podcasts
but uh my best friend uh from graduate
school is man by the name of professor
stefan alexander
stefan's at brown university yes uh you
should get this book i'll send you this
book actually
i have this miguel i'll send you oh you
have his book awesome brother not only
that right
but i bought um so i bought a used copy
and it's signed oh awesome oh well that
is awesome
phenomenal i hope it's not like i
actually bought um bought a book once on
bought a copy of my book losing the
nobel prize on amazon
um used because i i need an extra copy
and
it was signed and it said you know dear
liz you know i'm so glad
to have you as a friend and i'm like
this person freaking sold my book
but anyway as you know stefan talks
about this deep link going back to the
greeks
and music and in science and how the
universe and his conception
is a form of improvisation and the laws
of physics as con constituted by people
like richard feynman
and murray gelman and others uh manifest
a beautiful musical symmetry that we can
actually
tap into using different kind of
sensorial mechanisms like
our eyes and our ears so that plays into
two things you stumped me a few months
ago you asked me
to paint or illustrate uh the multiverse
so when i started trying to
conceptualize what that could be
in my interpretation i
started to uh i went back to
my first spark there's three
instances of my life that sparked my
love and passion for
music and sound and one of those
was when my mom
for my first grade science project was
she's a former member of uh acquire in
puerto rico
and my grandma founded it and so my mom
sang at carnegie hall when she was eight
years old and you know she's
managed a bunch of artists and so my mom
says
uh for your science experiment she goes
you know when you take a sword and you
just whoosh
you know and you wish it and you got
that sound well
that's because of the motion and the
planets
probably have a tone and i'm like
going back kepler kepler would be proud
of mom
you know and i was like that's awesome
it's the scale it's the scale it's the
whole scale
eight planets eight notes you know so
you know so that that started my uh
interest and passion and
pursuing what what that mystery is and i
think that that plays into
uh the whole multiverse theories
and concepts you know how and and also
to the creation which is
also i wanted to talk to you about um
you know with the cmb
and uh inflation and it's like how much
does sound play into that and is like
how are are we just not capturing uh
because i know you know it's
electromagnetic uh disruptions that
you know you can calculate what the tone
is it's like god about are our
instruments not
to the point where we can hear those
tones yet or how
how does that play in to yeah it's very
interesting we
uh we started to listen in on the
universe literally through the ligo
experiment
right did something that we had never
done before
exactly akin to what galileo did back
in 1610 when he used his little
telescope here
which you know again this is the
christmas season i'm often asked you
know what kind of telescope you should
get
for kids so get anything i got to come
out with we got to come out with the
tully keating
telescope you know painted bespoke
telescope because
uh i get asked so much for that we got
to have some some merch
monetization is the future of our of our
podcast man
but anyway so i look at it and i um and
i think
it's basically i don't want to say it's
a crime but but if you have kids or you
know kids
you should get them a telescope because
when i was a kid at age 13
i got my first telescope and 12 13
and i didn't live you know on the top of
mauna kea
or in arecibo or you know wherever i
lived in the middle you know just north
of new york city
in the biggest metropolis in the country
and i could see the same craters on the
moon
the phases of venus eclipses of the sun
i could see all the same things that
galileo could see
400 years ago and that inspired in me
i often say you can't possibly
replicate the feeling of discovering the
higgs boson i don't care who you are
first of all it took 6 000 people
20 years and 25 billion euros to do that
right
but you can exactly feel the emotion
that galileo had when he looked
and saw the moon was pockmarked with
craters or
jupiter had moons orbiting around i want
to encourage people to go out
tonight and look towards the setting sun
about you know half an hour after the
sun sets you'll see the moon
and you'll see two planets you'll see
two bright planets they're about to
merge almost
in an event on monday the 21st the first
day of winter in the northern hemisphere
and i always have to caution that
because i have a lot of listeners at the
south pole
so i have to say it's the first day of
summer for you brothers down there but
but for us up here
we gotta uh we got to get ready for it
for a long winter ahead of us
but anyway it's jupiter and saturn yeah
they're coming
together they're making what's called a
conjunction and those two planets if you
have a small telescope just whip it out
or even binoculars you'll see the rings
of saturn
the craters on the moon the moon's been
illuminated with earth shine
which is light that's reflected from the
sun hits
the earth bounces to the moon bounces
back to the earth it's unbelievable
that's how you can see the uniluminated
side of the moon
even tonight perhaps if it's clear where
you're at anyway
ligo what they did is they looked and
they found that the universe had
distinct sounds it had tones that it was
playing
and these tones happen every couple of
months they'll hear this very
interesting
sound which you know i have on my um on
my uh you know you have on your dj
equipment you know that's
kind of like the whoops you know it's a
chirp yeah you could probably do it lay
one of those out right now actually
you should put that in i want to hear
that one of your tracks brother i want
to hear you put in
the ligo chirp okay absolutely because
you can hear it
i'll put that you can hear two objects
30 times
more massive than the sun going half the
speed of light
colliding together to make an object
that's
59 times the mass of the sun so there's
one
mass of the entire sun that dissipated
throughout the universe in the form of
waves of gravity
and you can hear those waves of gravity
as they enter laboratories in
washington state and louisiana and they
made a cell phone ringtone based on it
and you can put it into your into your
music i'd love to hear something
inspired by the sounds of the universe
and just to close that out my good
friend jana levin professor at barnard
and columbia college she wrote a book
called black hole blues
and it's all about how long how
challenging
it was to hear the universe in sound
not light not neutrinos not meteorites
not even the photons from the big bang
that i study but to hear
the reverberations of space and time
itself i can't recommend it highly
enough yeah
that's incredible and uh yeah i do have
aspirations to
um i used to do ambient albums um
you know stefan alexander talks about
brian brian eno
and um you know i love his ambient work
it's like okay he's coined that word
um yeah so i like to merge those layers
it's like
modern but um back to the telescope so
the the thing that fascinates me about
telescopes
or is that they're so simple
and so you if you can talk about
your bicep telescope how did you
conceptualize the bicep
um especially um you know
that aspect like used milk jugs you know
literally
in the same the same material yeah so
here's the telescope isn't so great but
it kind of looks like a pirate's gonna
use this
uh but it's very similar to what galileo
used in 1610 you're talking 410 years
ago
no one had ever thought to take this
little spyglass and look up it's crazy
to think about it
but it wasn't only what you know he
thought to do that night he didn't
invent it
um but he perfected it he made it have
enough magnification
he also did some stuff to make the
aperture more
clear more clean he could make the glass
really perfectly smooth and so forth
and he realized that he could improve it
and enough
that he could see things that no person
had ever seen before and i kind of feel
like
i'm not comparing myself to galileo but
that um
but that i did the same kind of a thing
i noted that there was a
a type of telescope called a refracting
telescope a telescope with lenses
that could measure these imprints of the
early universes
bursting forth in what's called
inflation this
spark that ignited the big bang that
edwin hubble observed with galaxies all
rushing away
and what i realized is that we could do
that with a small telescope and small
in astronomy equates to cheap so this
telescope has a one inch diameter
uh lens if you wanted to make the
biggest lens type telescope ever
really made only had a diameter 40 times
this
so in other words a 40 inch lens is
about this big
that telescope this costs ten dollars
that telescope in today's dollars would
be like
a hundred million dollars okay uh so the
size of the telescope
uh depend the price of the telescope
depends on the size of the
of the lens to the third power so kind
of like the cube
of the size of the lens so if you want
to make something 40 times bigger
let's just do it 100 times bigger talk
about 100 cubed
so you're talking you know 10 to the uh
10 to the eighth dollars
yes okay yes exactly for my layout
answer um so inflation
correct me if i'm wrong it's basically
like the rapid expansion of space time
correct and if that did occur which we
don't know we have circumstantial
evidence that it occurred but we don't
have definitive proof that it occurred
so my hope was that this experiment
called bicep
which is uh pictured over my shoulder up
here at the south pole let me go there
it is
if you're watching and that telescope is
at the south pole
the actual axis in which the earth is
spinning around
uh uh around on its axis every every day
every 24 hours
so that telescope housed a refracting
telescope with a diameter of about this
big about
about a foot across and that telescope
was hoped for to go back as early as we
could
not really using light although we do
use the heat from the microwave
background
but really what we were looking for are
these waves of gravity
but not from black holes but from the
entire universe accelerating expanding
faster than the speed of light a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second after the big
bang
okay so when you're when you're using
these frequencies so
uh the bicep originally only had one
frequency
is that correct yeah and then and then
the bicep two and it had two in the in
the beginning
bicep one had two and then bicep two had
one which is weird
you'd think it would get better but
actually we we reduced it for for a
specific reason
now how um so is is the knowledge
already there that
we needed to use these frequencies to
see this
or was that something that you had to
conceptualize you know is that like a
as a free parameter yeah we knew that we
with bicep one
which is the one the first telescope
that i invented
and really the first telescope ever
uniquely deployed so that it could
detect the
origin of the universe through this
gravitational wave signal called b mode
polarization right that uh that
telescope i knew that we would
be confronted by not only seeing uh
the light that we wanted to see from the
universe's origin but also from
other contaminating sources that are out
in the cosmos or not like from a cell
phone nearby or
a microwave oven although we do worry
about things like that
but instead uh were from uh particles of
dust little grains
smaller than these meteorites here i
think i sent you one um
these these tiny meteorites are the
shrapnel
of exploded stars yeah there you go yeah
my favorite object so they can
ah that's awesome so uh i'm gonna get
you some dust
next gift you're gonna get in this
advent season i'm gonna send you some
meteorite powder
and what i want you to do is mix that in
with your paint yes and you can paint
the bicep yes uh me you know with cosmic
dust as your
on your canvas now do that okay
incredible
i can't even it's our next our next
project i'm going to get that for you i
actually
i don't know do you do any sculpting do
you do any sculpting
i'm trying to i'm trying well i do also
paint with
uh dust and and um so what i i have
series
and one of the series i did all my
um military um just my military ribbons
in a big
abstract form but i mixed in dust from
afghanistan iraq from korea
and uh from puerto rico and from and
from the us
um into these fathers campuses so yeah
the
mixing the stardust would be so it turns
out um
it turns out that um it's illegal if you
own
a moon rock that actually came was
collected by one of the astronauts those
are property of nasa
wow i do have moon rocks i don't know if
i sent you one if not i'll send you one
okay i have a little tiny sliver of a
moon rock that wasn't delivered by nasa
it was delivered by the us postal
service
because it came from a meteorite impact
or gravity delivered it
so a meteorite hit the moon and made a
crater
and shot up debris from the moon that
moon dust went around the earth and
eventually the earth plowed into it and
a rock
about you know twice the size of one of
these guys landed in africa
okay and um i i bought it and then i can
grind that up but
what's interesting is that one of the
astronauts in the apollo program
they all came back affected deeply
affected uh by going to the moon's
surface
but they realized that one of them
realized that they were allowed to keep
their own spacesuits
or they were allowed to like wash it or
something and before this guy washed it
he was like wait a second i got moon
dust on my space suit that nobody's
nobodies wanted to collect and he washed
off the the space dust at home before he
gave his spacesuit back to nasa to go to
the smithsonian or whatever
and he took the dust and he put it into
paint
so he's got lunar dust uh and paint but
you're gonna get the same thing
i'm gonna give you the same thing
because i i didn't get it from mike from
going there
anyway um the reason i ask is that one
project i'd love to do with you
is to take some of these meteorites so
this powder and melt it down
okay and i want to make meteorite rings
i want to make rings made of meteorite
and i want to engrave on them
like memory morty like you're going to
die memento mori
or you know remember you're going to be
stoic about life
as as many people say or you know that
my catchphrase is like add astra per
pelvis which means
to the stars through the dust yes and
you know that i'm i'm a biblical
observant guy and you know i noted back
after i wrote my book
you know that the bible talks about two
aspects of humans being dust adam the
first man the word adam in hebrew
means dirt because he was made from dirt
according i don't believe the literal
interpretation of it but i'm just saying
the metaphorical allegorical tale
is very beautiful and then what happens
at the end of your life in judaism
you're not supposed to be cremated
you're supposed to be buried
and deep and just in a pine box and
that's it no fancy mausoleum no
cremation
so that you return as it says to dust
and there's many examples of dust so i
realized wow that's kind of interesting
that means man's birth is dust
and that means man's end is dust so all
that matters
the only thing you have to do is that
between two dusts
like the dust that you were formed the
dust that you're going to come and it
really was powerful to me
uh especially since dust was the obs
obstacle to me
winning this nobel prize which i stole
from one of my guests who's on the show
frank will
no no it's a piece of chocolate but but
anyway
so i want to take these meteorites send
them to you or somebody they have to be
melted at extremely high temperatures so
you're going to have to look up
you know melting iron basically but if
we can do that and mold that we can have
seriously we can make a serious amount
of money and it would be really powerful
very cool to do that for people around
the world to have a fragment of four
billion year old
space dust to remind them every day that
they're mortal
you know it's um
surfing uh so yeah yeah
so yeah there's some out here for me
there's nothing better than surfing in
sports
that was the best so talk to me about
this yeah i got this and i'm treating it
like
you know i'm treating it like you know
it's a it's a data file
from from uh from from the voyager
spacecraft so talk to me about what what
this is
yeah you sent me a note but i want your
listeners to hear about it too it's so
cool i'm keeping it next to my
my data here i'll show you what it's
next to yeah so i'm i gave them to
um uh two people important in my life
and that have influenced me a lot um one
of them
scooter braun i'd send one of them and
uh
shea mooney from dan and shea and a
couple of other people so
um i just made 10 copies oh and my
friend tribby as well
so i made 10 copies of it and it's
literally just
to show my progress and growth i've been
producing music
since i was literally like four or five
years old you know just like recording
on a tape recorder
and trying to figure out how microphones
were working
i used to rig my headphones in reverse
and i would record my guitars with that
and to like
sound whatever it was with um
with windows like the first windows you
know they had like the sound recorder
windows media player media player yeah
and um
so it's just my evolution my growth
because you know you listen my stuff now
has nothing like all that stuff that's
on the tape is probably
to me it's garbage so that's why i
started a podcast it's called producer
trash
and um i had the idea because i'm just
like listening to all those songs from
10 years ago
and i'm just like oh my god this is
trash
just horrible so um
yeah i just wanted to kind of mark my
and to somebody that would keep it as
well
you know my just my growth so i can look
back at it in 10 20 years as well
um so that's what's very much that's
what the tape treasure that yeah thank
you
so this is from 2018 i see yeah it
starts off in 2008
and so as my songs from 2008 and i
stopped
making those kind of songs in 2018 and
it's just
this is there so it's an archive tape
basically yeah yeah i think i'll get you
five
yeah and then i'm broken on purpose
the thing was broken so i had to put
some artwork on it you know
um but yeah i started making electronic
dance music which is kind of the form
uh that in ambient music i had another
side project
and um trying to you know there's
there's like a scientific aspect of it
is you know i'd kind of use like the
scientific method to develop
songs and figure out what's working and
so i started in iraq um
on my laptop you know trying just to get
down
you know oscillation and how oscillators
work together
and frequencies and making tones and all
that stuff so
um yeah just kind of been growing from
that and now i'm just more
i think i'm more evolved and now i
finally get it i think i'm on day one
every single day
of my music journey i'm just like oh i'm
brand new you know
yeah that's the beginner's mind you
gotta have it
that's uh you know that to me is the uh
is the true key you've got to you've got
to
maintain kind of a humility being humble
and in science too
yeah that's the scientific method if you
ever get haughty or whatever
it's uh that's the end you're not gonna
yeah you're not gonna possibly be able
to succeed if that's your if that's your
notion of where you're at
uh yeah yeah yeah i always feel like
it's just day one
um and and also um you know
it means a lot to hear back from you on
the on the songs and things like that
too
because it helps i love it yeah i'm
putting them on my podcast cool
thank you so yeah i'm hoping uh you'll
take uh so
i'm hoping i can get a copy of this
video after we're done
and i want to put it on my channel today
as a little uh kind of bonus track
for my listeners and then maybe we'll
add some um add some music to it or
whatever but
keep it there but then you've got to
answer my questions yeah you got to
answer my final three questions
tell me tell me when you're ready for
that because i always have
different uh answers every single time
that i listen to it and i
you know it's kind of self self
experience it'll be a snapshot it'll be
it'll be an archived uh podcast
in 10 years we'll come back and we'll
listen to it yeah all right you want to
do it now
should i ask you my my final questions
yeah let's do awesome man
and you kind of talk just for your
audience so i run this uh
into the impossible podcast on apple and
i run uh
dr brian keating dr brian keating on
youtube and twitter
and uh instagram and my thing is that i
want to ask
the greatest minds and the greatest
creative people that have influenced me
that inspire me
i literally listen to miguel's music
when i'm when i got a big project i turn
on distraction free mode
i start typing away and i just go into
another place my wife jams out to it
uh she's a big fan former denverite too
denver center as she which i don't think
exists anymore but
uh but anyway we um so we asked these
great performers
ranging from billionaires to submarine
commanders
to uh to you know startup entrepreneurs
people like noah kagan jordan harbinger
james altucher
trying to get mark cuban to come on the
show uh and then uh eight nobel prize
winners pulitzer prize winners and i
asked them
these questions that i think will be
evocative
of their personalities because what i
want most that the stereotype of a
scientist is someone who can't even look
at
you know your shoes when he talks to you
right so he can only look down at his
own shoes so
for the scientists i want to get them
out of the shell and make them more like
the entrepreneurs and
for the entrepreneurs i want them to
think more deeply about the big
questions so
i found these three questions really tie
into
what uh what makes people unique so i'm
going to start off you ready miguel yes
let's do it all right can you provide in
three sentences or less a unification of
quantum mechanics with gravity
that works in 16 dimensions or more
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding that's
not one of the questions i just wanted
to stump him
gotta stump you all right first question
there's a concept in my religion in
judaism
of an ethical will and as i talk about
in the book alfred nobel had an ethical
will he had a material will
that he want to give money uh uh to give
money
to people to actually uh make the world
better in addition to this
golden medallion that they get he said
you have to discover or invent something
that benefits greatly all of mankind
so it was an ethical will it wasn't just
what he wanted done with his money
uh in hebrew it's called a zava ah and i
wanna know
for people i don't think you don't have
kids right so uh it's a little
i got enough kids for both of us but
you've got siblings and you influence
them i'm sure
and uh they probably look up to you as a
role model as i do i look up to you and
i honor what you've done for the country
and for the world and for me personally
but i want to ask you what do you want
to give to the world not in terms of
your money or your artwork
but something intangible a non-physical
that will outlast you in term and
benefit mankind in the same way that say
the nobel prize did in terms of your
ethics
wisdom or morals i would have to say
um if a feeling doesn't count as a
substance it's just like the
feeling to to be and to do good
you know and to pass that on through you
know you can do that through example
so i would say that the feeling that's
great because i mean if everybody
can feel that you know yeah
i think it would resonate that's
wonderful
um i don't know if you ever saw the
movie 2001 a space odyssey no
it's a movie that i recommend people
watch um it's uh it's it's an old movie
uh it's actually way older than 2001
even
but it uh it's about kind of the
progress of humanity
from you know the primates on the
savannahs of africa all the way up
through
you know the space age and landing on
the moon and there's an
obelisk in this that kind of looks like
this tape but but black
okay and it appears in different
contexts so
initially these these cavemen and women
find it and they're hitting it with a
bone and they don't know what to do with
it
and then later they find it on the
surface of the moon when nasa sends
astronauts to the moon
and it's clearly meant to be like a time
capsule that can last a billion years
and i asked um carl sagan's widow so
carl sagan's widow is andrew and she
runs the cosmos program
on on tv with neil degrasse tyson my
kid's favorite astrophysicist
and uh and carl sagan and and andrew
and actually did this so she said i put
a golden record
on the voyager spacecraft and that
voyager spacecraft has
music has a disc made of solid gold that
has music from all these cultures around
the earth and actually miguel
this was the first example of what's
called ethno ethnic
world music sorry ethan musicography and
world music so i encourage you to look
it up but
i want to ask you if you were going to
make a time capsule like the voyager
record that lasts for a billion years
she said
what would you put on it what would you
put in it would it be one of your songs
would it be someone else's songs what
would you put on it for a future
civilization to discover a billion years
from now
um selfishly it would be my music
and um the reason that i would answer
that is
because when i when i wrote when i write
music
and when i write poetry and when i'm
writing my book as well it's
for me it's just like that's just a
stamp of what's there but also
shows what people are going through
in general and you know not to be like
oh this is humanity it's just
from my perspective and i don't know how
anybody else's perspective is so that's
why i would just leave my music
i would leave it specifically on my
roland
sp 404 sx which is a
sampler that's super powerful and i can
load
all my songs onto it
and uh i would put you know a pack of
batteries in there so you know
double a's that's right you know if they
get this thing
you know they're not gonna know what to
do with it so yeah i mean if
you're looking at a capsule like that
for me it would be
you know to document history so um you
know you talk about
in my time uh iraq
you know you have afghanistan and you
got
standing rock which is very important
for me i was there during that time and
now you have these protests you know and
things like that so
yeah i put my music in there on sp404sx
final answer awesome very good the last
question
has to do not with going forward in time
like those other two questions are going
backwards in time
okay so arthur c clarke who is the
namesake of the center at ucsd that i
co-direct
says arthur c clark center for human
imagination
he had three laws three famous laws the
first one is any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic his
second law was for every expert there's
an equal and opposite
expert uh and his third law and i've had
that on i've had on
ben shapiro on my show and i've had on
noam chomsky
on my show that was a great uh you gotta
get it for all of him
he's great um so i got a dolla ham i got
all these dolls
um but i want to ask you his third law
is the only way to find out
the limits of what is possible is to
venture beyond
into the impossible that's the name of
my podcast so i'm gonna ask you what as
a 20-something
seemed impossible uh to you miguel and
yet because of your courage and
fortitude became possible
and allowed you to see the limits and
the boundaries on what is possible for
you
advice to your former self
i'd say
for me it's physically nothing's
impossible but mentally i'm still
discovering those boundaries you know
like how can i conceptualize
what the beginning of the universe was
or looked like how is sound you know
how is how is sound like what is
well what's dark matter you know what is
consciousness
you know and those kind of things um i
would say to myself to explore those
more deeply and
not be focused on the physical
limitations
and and great traverse the minds
universe i call it the yeah the mental
multiverse
yeah that's what i call awesome man well
we're uh we're brothers from another
mother i hope to meet you someday i'm
gonna
i'm gonna sign off i want to ask people
ask you where can people
in my audience find you first of all
where are you located
online and where's your other where can
people find and buy your art et cetera
awesome yetiteers.com y-e-t-i-t-e-a-r-s
dot-com and all my social media
platforms are yetiteers.com
um i did have one more question for you
about uh yeah i
literally wrote it down the legacy box
question i was like hey
i i just wonder is it is it your book
is it what would you put in the box
oh that's a good question you know for
me um
for me i think you know i get a lot of
my values from the old testament from
the torah the bible um
and and and i think you know my legacy
i always say there is one and only one
proven form of time travel and that's
you know children and that doesn't mean
biological children only
could be adopted children it could be
ideological children
my graduate students are every bit as
close you know to me as as some members
of my family maybe more so
i spend more time with them uh you know
than than my cousins who i love so much
but the point is um you can influence
people even if you're not a parent
to transmit your values into time into
the future
you can't go back in time but you can go
forwards in time and so i'd most want to
you know kind of transmit the values
that it's what you do
outside of the laboratory or the office
or whatever
that's where your legacy is made and you
want to
um you want to live you know kind of a
humbly
humbly and with the understanding that
yes you are going to be dust
but your conscious dust your dust that
is unlike any other dust that's ever
existed and make
use of this precious sliver of time that
we get
between two dusts
all right dr keaton i just want to thank
you for your time everybody go pick up
the book
losing the nobel prize it is as science
says
riveting and i enjoyed it very much and
i appreciate you
and look forward to speaking with you in
the future again thanks doctor
thanks miguel yeah let's talk about our
uh next project to make uh make a ring
of meteorites
and uh and some lunar dust paintings
that's what i want next
have a great holiday season miguel thank
you so much for having me on and yeah
send me a link to the or send me a
download link for the video so i can
upload it to youtube
absolutely thank you all right brother
be well thank you so much
you